[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 24 décembre
voici l'essentiel de l'actualité locale
du jour à quelques heures du réveillon
de noël l' ultime rush dans les magasins
les retardataires étaient nombreux à la
recherche du cadeau de dernière minute
exemple dans une enseigne de jouets à
rambouillet et dans une librairie à
montigny le bretonneux avec mathilde de
demi livre de cuisine bandes dessinées
mangas ou encore prix goncourt il y en a
pour tous les goûts en ce 24 décembre
sillonnant les allées à la recherche du
livre parfait les retardataires se
presse avant de fêter le réveillon
je suis à la recherche d'un roman
historique qu'elle n'a pas lu mais comme
je suis pas tellement au fait de et de
ce qu'elle a lu ce qu'est la palud donc
je ne peu perplexe c'est vraiment les
derniers achats donc effectivement je
pense que je suis un peu comme beaucoup
de monde le dernier moment j'ai pas eu
le temps de boucler mes cadeaux donc
j'ai des petits cadeaux de dernière
minute à faire ce matin donc c'est un
petit peu la course
le livre un cadeau incontournable qui
sera au pied du sapin demain matin la
librairie du pavé du canal s'est préparé
au rush des cadeaux de dernière minute
il ya beaucoup de monde encore
aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
tout le monde n'a pas fait ses cadeaux
de noël
donc les gens sont plutôt exigeant donc
on essaye de répondre au mieux à leurs
attentes et leur proposer le meilleur
service possible jusque jusqu'à ce soir
18 heures du côté des jouets la reine
des neiges
harry potter et star wars sont les
cadeaux phare de ce noël 2010 neuf dans
cette enseigne de jouets à rambouillet
certains sont en quête des derniers
cadeaux en espérant qu'ils seront
toujours en rayon je suis venu chercher
un jouet un barbie licorne
j'ai écumé 3 4 magasins dans la région
pour là j'ai pas trouvé
je n'ai pas pris le temps de venir
chercher des cadeaux avant et je trouve
ça quand même important d'offrir des
cadeaux donc j'ai quand même j'avais
beaucoup de choses à faire et donc voilà
donc à de nouvelles idées qui arrive
donc je viens je viens prendre pour
compléter on va dire depuis novembre le
magasin accueille tous les jours ses
clients mais aujourd'hui chacun
d'obtenir sa liste de cadeaux destinés
au père noël
on a eu énormément de clients donc notre
travail
c'était de bien les recevoir et surtout
leur trouver des produits qu'il
souhaitait et de d'avoir les bons
produits avec un magasin plein
et puis d'être à leur écoute pour le
retrouver tout ce qui leur manque là sur
la dernière ligne droite
et même si ces cadeaux sont achetés à la
dernière minute ils seront tout de même
apprécié demain matin sous le sapin
on sait fêtes de fin d'année le temps
est à la décoration certains yvelinois
en plus du sapin à l'intérieur on paraît
totalement l'extérieur de leur maison et
de quoi illuminer la nuit de manière
féerique à jouars-pontchartrain nous
avons croisé la route de deux maisons
père noël très noren ours pingouins
mêmes célèbre bonhomme de neige étaient
de sortie tout comme les guirlandes
lumineuses
on écoute ses décorateur qui ont mis
entre trois et dix jours à tout
installer on habite là depuis deux mois
de mai et pour la première fois on va
recevoir nos petits enfants à la maison
je trouve que c'est un peu magique là ça
surtout mon mari en fait qu'il a
découvert au pouvoir a toutes décorées
après je pense c'est aussi pour les
enfants et puis pour la magie de noël
enfin ça vous plaît oui vous êtes
content comme java et les allume quand
vous rentrez de l'école il a acheté en
fait au fur et à mesure je d'année en
année on complète la collection et puis
voilà après il met un certain temps de
s'installer dans le reste de l'actualité
en bref cinq mois après l'incident ppj
valide et pour l' usine seine aval du
siaap lé préfet des yvelines et du val
d'oise viennent d'adopter ce plan
particulier d'intervention depuis l'
incendie de la station d'épuration le 3
juillet dernier qui a engendré une
pollution de la senne et la mort de plus
de trois tonnes de poissons et les
autorités travaillaient sur le dossier
le pays est un dispositif local qui a
une vocation d'information et
d'organisation préventive des secours et
des scénarios d'accidents industriels
sont identifiés tout comme les
populations fragiles un périmètre de
sécurité est définie et des mesures de
protection mises en place le détail de
ce plan particulier d'intervention est à
consulter sur le site internet de la
préfecture des yvelines a voisins le
bretonneux les concepteurs du futur
quartier de la remise connu suite à un
appel à projet les promoteurs du grand
paris associé ali vaisseau death ainsi
que deux bailleurs sociaux ont été
choisis par la ville et saint quentin en
yvelines 500 logements doivent sortir de
terre dans les premiers
en 2022 notamment 180 logements sociaux
et 235 en accession l'éco quartier
comprendra également 1700 m² de
commerces et des services
la remise devrait être totalement
terminé d'ici quatre ans avant de vous
laisser direction bonnel le parc de la
haute vallée de chevreuse vous propose
de participer à des chantiers nature
chaque année il faut nettoyer et
entretenir ces sites pour sauvegarder
est la variété des paysages et ses
milieux naturels de la réserve on enfile
ses bottes avec gwenaëlle sentiment en
ce début d'hiver le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
la commune de bonnel et l'association
bullion bonnel nature ont invité les
habitants à venir participer à un
chantier nature sur la réserve naturelle
régionale des étangs de bonnel au
programme de ce dimanche matin
l'entretien et la restauration d'une
roselière avec création de mares et même
d'abri pour animaux sauvages la
roselière c'est un milieu ouvert donc
qui a besoin de lumière besoin dos à
l'eau elle est là mais par contre besoin
de lumière donc on a
on a travaillé à du petit bûcheronnage
pour couper quelques petits arbres et
quelques un peu plus grand et puis
ensuite baranger tout ça bien proprement
venir à remettre la roselière en lumière
pour qu elle ce qu'elle puisse se
développer
s'agrandir un petit peu et puis et puis
éviter que ça se trouve que le milieu se
referme avec ses 2 étend ses sources
s'arrose lierse et boisement ces
prairies et la rivière gloriette la
réserve naturelle présente une
remarquable variété de paysages et de
milieux naturels qu'il faut préserver
alors si vous souhaitez planter des
haies et des arbres fruitiers ou même
revaloriser des fontaines n'hésitez pas
à venir donner un peu de votre temps et
de votre énergie pour apporter votre
contribution à la préservation de la
biodiversité et des paysages du parc
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité l'info locale revient
jeudi 26 décembre même heure et d'ici là
passez un très bon noël
et n'oubliez pas celui qui conduit c'est
celui qui ne boit pas prudence sur les
routes belle fête sur tv 78
[Musique]